un déjà Vu se vive Ni si un tras retomar
el control de las manos rusas en la
ciudad al noreste de Ucrania las fuerzas
armadas del país encontraron fosas
comunes en las que habrían más de 440
cuerpos de personas asesinadas por
ataques aéreos o bombardeos unos
descubrimientos que encendieron
nuevamente las alarmas del país
se encontraron fuerzas comunes en
edición en la región de harkin ya se han
iniciado los procedimientos legales
necesarios allí Rusia está dejando
muerte detrás de Sí en todas partes y
debe hacerse responsable
los hallazgos de edición revivieron los
horrores del pasado reciente la ciudad
de ucha cerca de kiev fue el primer
escenario de descubrimiento similares
tras el retiro de las tropas rusas de
las inmediaciones de la capital otros
400 civiles asesinados entonces selensky
catálogo de genocidio las acciones rusas
Estos son crímenes de guerra y serán
reconocidos por el mundo como genocidio
los macabros hallazgos en mucha pusieron
en el centro del debate de los posibles
crímenes de guerra cometidos por Rusia
en territorio ucraniano y llegó a varios
líderes mundiales a exigir una
investigación a profundidad un pedido
atendido por la Corte Penal
Internacional que envió un equipo al
lugar
si hay delitos los jueces tienen que
decidir si deben emitir un órdenes o
citaciones pero tenemos que ir paso a
paso y esto es parte de eso
luego de ducha llegó borovianca cuando
las pesquisas ucranianas llevaron a
selenski a asegurar que la tragedia
podría ser peor que la debucha el
panorama de la ciudad indignó al
secretario general de Naciones Unidas
nuestros corazones por supuesto están
con las víctimas nuestras condolencias a
sus familias
No hay forma de que una guerra pueda ser
aceptable en El Siglo 21
a medida que Ucrania gana terreno señala
que está encontrando pistas para
sustentar sus acusaciones de crímenes de
guerra cometidos por Rusia unas que
Moscú desmiente asegurando no haber
atacado a civiles